this is something I learned from Avatar
as well the show which my nickname comes
from uh yeah when he met Guru Pitta and
he had to learn how to detach himself
from worldly possessions because he
wanted to be able to control the Avatar
state
there were seven chakras he had to
unlock and one of them was Detachment
the hardest one for him was the tax was
was from Katara but for me what am I
attached to
I guess my family first of all because
they will always be there they've been
there before all this happened
they've been there before all this so
they will always be there so I'm
attached to them
um my dogs keep them with me
um I'm attached to them
and my
uh my gym yes my training my training my
my values in that space But yeah any
material things I'm not really attached
to material things I'm not I love them
don't get me wrong I like to [ __ ]
floss I'm light right now but yeah I
like to flex but I'm not attached to
those things I don't like they don't
Define me I make them they don't make me